Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Cevick. Ich bin heute Ihre zuständige Ärztin auf dieser Station und möchte mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Aber natürlich. Bitte schön.
Okay. Bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden nennen, bräuchte ich einige persönliche Daten.
Sie können jederzeit fragen, wann etwas Ihnen unklar ist.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Hans Kanton.
Könnten Sie mir Ihren Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Kanton, wie in der Schweiz Kanton, also K-A-N-T-O-N.
Okay, Herr Kanton. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
Wie waren Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. August, 1900, was habe ich gesagt, 48?
76? Nein, 78.
78, ja.
76?
Ja, 76.
Pardon.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Kanton?
1,95 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ja, ein Moment, ein bisschen viel, 123 kg.
132?
23.
23, okay.
Vielen Dank für die Angaben, Herr Kanton.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich weiß nicht, wo ich anfangen soll.
Ich habe viele Beschwerden in den letzten 2-3 Tagen.
Ich habe seit ungefähr einem halben Jahr merke ich,
dass meine Luft bei Belastung immer weg bleibt, immer knapper wird.
Aber ich habe das nicht ernst genommen.
Jetzt wird das schlimmer.
Seit 3 Tagen habe ich so einen enge Gefühl und so einen Druck auf den Brust.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt Angst bekommen und bin hergekommen.
Sie haben seit einem halben Jahr Luftnot immer schlimmer geworden.
Seit 2-3 Tagen auch Luftnot und enge Gefühl.
Ja, genau.
Wo fühlen Sie diese enge Gefühl hinter dem Brustbein?
Hier vorne, genau.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Strahl ein bisschen in den Hals
und so ein bisschen in die linke Schulter manchmal.
Und der linke auch manchmal komisch.
Genau.
Okay.
Herr Kanton, muss ich jetzt diese Gespräche kurz unterbrechen?
Ich muss Ihre Kreislaufwerte erst mal messen.
Ihre Vitalparameter werden von meinen Kollegen gemessen
und ich schreibe Ihnen ein EKG.
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist, können wir unser Gespräch fortfahren.
Ist das was Schlimmes?
Ja, ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, aber es könnte sein.
Aus Sicherheit wollte ich diese Untersuchungen erst mal durchführen.
Und auch Sauerstoffsetigung werde ich messen
und wir kommen Sie über die Nase, damit wir unsere Kreislaufwerte fortführen können.
Okay.
Sie haben enge Gefühl und auch haben Sie Schmerzen an der Brust?
Nicht immer, das kommt und geht.
Nur manchmal.
Wann kommen die Schmerzen?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, zum Beispiel bei Bewegung und Belastung?
Also wie ich schon sagte, wenn ich zu stark belaste, dann kommt es verstärkt.
Da kommt die Luftnot und danach dieses enge Gefühl.
Sie belassen zu stark und bekommen Sie diese Schmerzen, enge Gefühl und auch Luftnot?
Ja.
Okay.
Zum Beispiel, wie viele Treppen können Sie hochlaufen, ohne Luftnot zu bekommen?
Also früher bin ich drei, vier Stockwerke ohne Pause gelaufen.
Okay, dass ich jetzt nach einem Stockwerk ein bisschen stehen muss,
ein bisschen Luft atmen muss und dann weitermachen kann.
Seit zwei, drei Tagen meinen Sie.
Nur ein Stockwerk können Sie schaffen und dann Pause machen.
Genau.
Okay.
Hatten Sie ganz früher nicht beschwerden oder nur halben Jahr?
Das ist das erste Mal eigentlich.
Diese erste Mal.
Okay.
Und in laufender Zeit diese Beschwerden immer Schildimmer geworden?
Ja.
Auch am Anfang sind diese Schmerzen oder diese ganze Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen
oder langsam können Sie sagen?
Also seit zwei Tagen ging es eigentlich akut, muss ich sagen.
Okay.
Und wie viel Tag sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalafon,
null bis zehn, wobei null keine Schmerzen sind,
sehr heftige Schmerzen entspricht?
Also wenn es mal mit diesem Engige für meinen Sie,
und die Schmerzen, so fünf, sechs, würde ich sagen, wenn es mal kommt.
Wenn es mal kommt, fünf, sechs.
Und wie lange dauert diese Engige-Gefühl?
Eine halbe Stunde bleibt das schon.
Halbe Stunde, okay.
Immer halbe Stunde ungefähr.
Wenn Sie kommen, den Sie dauerhaft.
Wie dauerhaft?
Das bleibt schon.
Und wie viel Meter können Sie laufen, ohne Schmerzen
oder ohne Engige-Gefühl, ohne Luftnot zu haben?
Ja, dazu.
Beim Laufen merke ich das nicht so.
Es ist mehr, wenn ich eine körperliche Anstrengung habe.
Okay.
Normaler laufen nicht.
Normaler laufen keine.
Okay.
Wie können Sie diese Engige-Gefühl und Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf, brennend, zähend, stechend?
Nee, das ist eher so, da habe ich das Gefühl,
als ein großer Elefant mehr auf der Brust sitzt.
Engige-Gefühl, ja, so ein Stechen ist das eigentlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Bist ja eigentlich noch nicht, nein.
Haben Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt gesucht?
War ich noch nicht.
Ich wollte eigentlich nächste Woche zum Hausarzt,
aber nach den Beschmerzen jetzt doch so heftig geworden sind,
bin ich gleich zu Ihnen hierhergekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Auslöser- oder Versteckfaktor,
außer Belastung bemerkt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Belastung, okay.
Was versteckt,
hat sich die Schmerzen erkannt und haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Nein, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Können Sie flach liegen in der letzten Zeit
oder seit diesen halben Jahren?
Flach liegen ist noch kein Problem, nein.
Okay, können Sie.
Haben Sie Beinschwellung?
Nein, bisher nicht, nein.
Beinschwellungen im Bein habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein, nicht, okay.
War Ihnen Schwindel?
Nein, Schwindelig.
Schwindelig.
Okay, nein.
Verspüren Sie Herzlagen, Herzstolpern oder Herzklopfen?
Also nicht, aber manchmal habe ich so einen kräftigen Herzschlag,
das stimmt.
Wenn die Schmerzen mal oder dieses Engelgeffen kommt,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, das klopft ganz kräftig
und das ist immer so, als ob es stolpert, diese Herzfrequenz.
Verspüren Sie diese Herzstolpern seit zwei bis drei Tagen oder?
Ja, da ist es verstärkt.
Das habe ich immer wieder gehabt, aber ich habe es nicht erkannt.
Okay, jetzt ist es stark.
Ja, ja.
Schwitzen Sie mehr Herkantun oder kalte Schweiz, haben Sie bemerkt?
Das habe ich nicht, nein.
Fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Nein.
Nachtschweiß, haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Nein, habe ich auch.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Blasehaut oder leuliche Veränderungen
an der Haut bemerkt?
Bin ich aufgefallen, nein.
Nein, okay.
Und wie ist die Appetit?
Also bisher ganz gut, ich bin mit 120 kg.
Appetit, gut.
Und in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, alles unbefällt.
Okay.
Abnehmen, aber ich schaffe es nicht so.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Ab die Toilette in der Nacht?
Nein, nein.
Häufig?
Nein, alles gut.
Stuhl auch in Ordnung?
Ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel oder war Ihnen übelt herkantun?
Nein, wenn du es enger gefühl kommst, dann hat man das Gefühl, es ist eine leichte Übelkeit dabei.
Okay.
Nein, aber müssten Sie schon erbrechen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut, normalerweise?
Ja, aber ich habe kein Problem.
Okay.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen herkantun.
Leiden Sie andauerhaften Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheiten, Beispiel oder erhöhte Blutfettwerte könnte sein?
Bisher nichts bekannt, ja.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, aber wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich mal einen E-Bö-Profen, aber
ansonsten habe ich keine Medikamente.
Okay.
Und sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt herkantun?
Nein, nicht eigentlich.
Ich habe keine Erkrankungen.
Okay, und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Auch gegen Corona?
Mein Haushaus hat mich mal vor vielen angesprochen.
Ich glaube, es fehlen ein paar Impfungen.
Die Tetanus, müsste ich glaube ich erneuern.
Corona-Impfungen habe ich die letzten zwei nicht gemacht.
Ich hatte da vor, hatte ich zwei schon.
Okay, ja. Achten Sie darauf, ja, Aufricht, Impfungen sind wichtig.
Ja, am Haushalt auch immer so. Ich mag.
Okay, das verstehe ich. Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay, jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten. Herr Kanton, rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider habe ich dieses Lasten ja.
Wie viel rauchen Sie täglich und seit wann?
Fragen Sie nicht nach. Also, das kann schon sein, bis zwei Packungen am Tag.
Mhm.
Und?
Seit wann rauchen Sie so?
Auch über 30 Jahre schon.
35?
Ja, ungefähr.
Oh, das ist aber zu viel. Haben Sie einmal versucht, damit auch zu hören?
Ja, ich habe schon mehrfach, aber ich schaffte es irgendwie nicht.
Okay, ja. Wenn Sie wollen, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen.
Nach unserem Gespräch können wir darüber sprechen.
Wenn Sie wollen.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen erst mal hier.
Ja, natürlich.
Und das ist, glaube ich, eine langfristige Geschichte.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Kanton?
Ja, schon ab und zu.
Mhm. Was meinen Sie ab und zu, jeden Tag oder nur ab und zu?
Nur ab und zu.
Ja, so ein Bier am Abend, das können auch mal zwei Fleisch werden.
Ich glaube, das ist normal.
Sie sind hier auch Alkohol.
Mhm.
Aber manchmal zu einem Feier und auch mal ein Wein dazu.
Ja, okay. Feierlich dazu Wein, aber jeden Tag zwei Fleisch Bier täglich.
Ungefähr, ja.
Ungefähr. Seit wann?
Oh, auch schon.
22 Jahre, glaube ich.
Okay, das ist auch so viel.
Und jetzt, jetzt die Frage, nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Routimes-Gefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie einen Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ja, das meint ich jetzt genau mit Drogen.
Kokain oder Heroin habe ich nicht.
Aber kiffer manchmal schon.
Also das heißt, ich nehme Cannabis und so weiter.
Ja, das mache ich ab und zu.
Ja, Cannabis ab und zu nehmen Sie.
Okay.
Okay, ich denke.
Und jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familie sprechen.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Oh je, weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Ich habe auch wenig Kontakt zu meinen Eltern,
aber so weit ich weiß,
hat mein Vater, glaube ich, einen Blutdruck.
Ich meine, die sind beide ganz fit, ja.
Die machen Wanderungen, die reisen rum.
Und meine Mutter nimmt ja auch so vieles ein,
mit Vitaminen und was auch immer.
Ich glaube, die hat keine Grundschneidankung bis zu viel.
Okay, leben Sie noch?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Okay, Herr Kanton, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder hier.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, Glückwunsch.
Gott sei Dank.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Projektmanager.
Ja, gut.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Oh, nur.
Okay.
Und die letzte Frage,
wenn Sie diese enge Gefühl oder Luftnot
erst einmal bekommen haben,
in der letzten Zeit meine ich,
was haben Sie gemacht,
vielleicht viel Stress oder bei Belastung?
Ich meine, ich gebe das immer auf den Stress,
denn das haben wir jeden Tag.
Nicht besonders.
Okay.
Ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen, Herr Kanton,
möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, aber es ist aus dem EKG geworden.
Sie haben doch vorhin noch ein bisschen Blut abgenommen.
Sie haben schon Ergebnis im EKG, können Sie etwas sehen?
Jetzt gibt es keine Auffälligkeiten,
aber sollen wir nochmal diese EKG wiederholen.
Und natürlich, ich werde sie körperlich untersuchen
und ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Okay.
Aber nach Ihren Angaben,
das könnte vom Herz verursachen.
Ah, okay.
Ich habe noch eine Frage für Sie, Herr Kanton.
Ja bitte.
Also, haben Sie auch ein Angstgefühl mit den Schmessen dabei?
Angstgefühl?
Angstgefühl.
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ich habe noch eine Frage für Sie, Herr Kanton.
Ja bitte.
Also, haben Sie auch ein Angstgefühl mit den Schmessen dabei?
Angstgefühl.
Angstgefühl?
Es ist sehr beengend auf der Brüche.
Manchmal macht man Angst, aber es ist mehr mit dem Gefühl.
Das stimmt.
Müssten Sie nachts aufwachen?
Nein, das habe ich noch nicht erfahren.
Nein.
Okay, danke.
Schmerzintensität hat gefragt, hat gefragt, oder?
Herzkampf?
Ja.
5 oder 6 hat gesagt.
Dauergifrakt?
Hab auch gesagt, halbe Stunde je wurden.
Dauergifrakt, oder ich wäre gratifikifrakt.
Herz ist schon, ja.
Okay.
Benzi Brüche merzin bekommun geche noch etwas zu sagen,
bitte.
Ich habe gesagt nur Übelkeit.
Wenn Sie Brüche merzin haben, geche noch etwas zur Selbenzeit?
Nein, nein.
Nur Übelkeit?
Ja.
Okay.
Meine Fragen?
Natürlich hat gefragt.
Da machen wir alles als Gespräch?
Ja, bitte schön.
Brauchen Sie noch ein bisschen Zeit, Frau Doktor?
Ja, ich versuche.
Schönen Abend, liebe Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute mit einem neuen Patienten das an der Amnesi-Gespräch geführt.
Ah, Guten Abend, Frau Kolleginnen und neue Kolleginnen.
Und haben gut eingearbeitet.
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Ja, ganz gut.
Danke.
Okay, das freut mich.
Dann erzählen Sie mal,
wie Sie sich das überlegen.
Es handelt sich um Hans Kanton.
Herr Kanton sei 48 Jahre alt.
Am 3. und 26.
19 unter 76 geboren.
1,95 m groß und 123 kg schwer.
Herr Kanton stellte sich heute wegen seit 2-3 Tagen bestehende
akut aufgetretene,
progrediente,
dünne und seit 2-3 Tagen bestehende,
akut aufgetretene, belastung abhängiger,
progrediente.
Okay.
Die nächsten Monate, das ist nicht bei 3 Tagen.
Auch gleich.
Ich glaube, aber natürlich halben Jahr bestehende.
Ich sage danach das.
Und akut aufgetretene, belastung abhängiger,
progrediente.
Und retrosternal,
torakalgi, mit Ausstrahlung in den Halsbereich
und in den linken Arm bei uns vor.
Er ordnet die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalafon
bei 5-6 von 10 ein.
Und außer dann berichtet der Patient,
dass er ähnliche Beschwerden auch seit halbem Jahr
gehabt habe.
Und diese Schmerz- und engen Gefühl
dauere halbe Stunde.
Und der Patient könne früher 3-4 Stockwerke
Treppe hochlaufen.
Aber in der letzten Zeit könne er nur ein Stockwerk
hochlaufen.
Und dann müsste er Pause machen.
Und außer dann leide Herr Kanton als Begleitzentrum
unter Herzstolpern und engen Gefühl.
Die Fragen,
Herr Palpitationen sagen Sie, ja?
Ah, Palpitation, okay.
Und die Fragen nach Urtopne, Neutrik,
Turi, Beinüdem, Vertigo,
und wurden verneint.
Der Patient habe keine Medikamente bisher eingenommen
und auch habe er keinen Arzt besucht.
Die vegetative Anamnese zeigt leichte Nausea.
Ansonsten sind die anderen Informationen unauffällig.
Vor Erkrankungen und Operationen wurden verneint.
Die Medikamentanamnese gab die Einnahme von Ibu Profan
bei Bedarf.
Und beim Patienten sei keine Allergie bekannt
und der im Status sei nicht vollständig.
Gegen Corona haben die letzten zwei Impfungen
der Patient nicht machen lassen.
Und auch der Tönnisimpfung ist nicht vollständig.
Die Reiseanamnese sei unauffällig.
Herr Kanton ist raucher mit 2 Packungen täglich
seit 35 Jahren.
Das beträgt 70 Packungen.
Er trinkt Alkohol, täglich,
Zwerflerche, Biya seit 20 Jahren.
Manchmal Wein auch.
Und er rauchte Cannabis ab und zu.
Und der Anamnese leidet der Vater an Artere hypertonie
und die Mutter sei gesund.
Herr Kanton sei Einzelkind,
verheiratet habe zwei gesunde Kinder
und sei Projektmanager als von Beruf
und habe viel Stress auf der Arbeit.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten auf
am ehesten Akutes Corona-Sendrum hin.
Und als differenzial Diagnose kommen
Pneumotorax und Puminaremboli
und Angina Pectoris in Betracht.
Angina Pectoris ist auch eine Beschreibung
und der Symptome ist jetzt keine Erkrankung.
Ein BWS-Syndrom,
eine Buswerbesyndrom, Schmerzen
von der Wirbelsäule, die nach vorne aufstrahlt.
Ich dachte, ich mag Probleme,
als differenzial Diagnose könnte sein.
Oder Pneumotorax dachte ich.
Was darf es sein?
Noch differenzial Diagnostisch.
Ein enges Gefühl auf der Brust,
vielleicht noch einen Blutdruck.
Eine rizidivierende, hypertensive Entgleisung.
Vielleicht mal der Grund sein,
Magen gastrointrassinal beschwerden.
Ja, Ulcus ventricle.
Woran denkt man noch?
Irgendeine Arten?
Arten, Dissektion.
Oder Arten, Ektasie.
Also Probleme mit der Arter.
Können auch mal solche Beschwerden machen.
Ja, wenn du so viel rauchst,
woran denken sie noch?
COPD.
Das kann von der Lunge her kommen,
dass er einfach Schluckdruck bekommt.
Also, müssen wir auch mal gucken.
Aber ich glaube, das am wahrscheinlichsten ist,
wir müssen schauen, ob wir nicht ein Akkord des Corona-Ansyndroms
mit Bedacht auf Karakal rein.
So viel, Familienanämese, so viel rauchen.
Ja, die großkuläre Sterienübergewicht rauchen,
insbesondere.
Es kann auch immer sein, dass ein Jugend Mensch
auch mal eine KHK natürlich hat.
Sehr gut, okay.
Sie machen eine EKG und gedenken natürlich auch an einen Vorhof-Limmern.
Das kann ja manchmal auch solche Beschwerden machen,
dass man schlechter Luft bekommt.
Das Herz ist sehr gut.